Okay, Michael, so here's a quiz. Now it's a
pretty straightforward quiz. I just want you to use everything
that you've learned so far. Okay, so you have
three hypotheses. Let's call them h1, h2, and h3, okay?
>> Mm-hm.
>> For the sake of argument. Here's what each of these hypotheses Outputs
for some particular x. h1 says plus. h2 says minus. h3 says minus. Okay?
>> Mm-hm.
>> Now here we've,
already made it easy for you and we've
computed the probability of, a particular hypothesis given some
set of data. I'm not showing you the data
but I'm showing you the answer for it. Okay?
So the probability of h1 given the data is 0.4, h2 is 0.3, and h3 is 0.3.
Got it? Wait hang on, so, okay, I see
that corresponds here about this given data, what's x?
>> x is some input, it doesn't matter,
just like it doesn't matter what the date is.
>> [LAUGH] 'Kay.
>> Just
call it so that, that, x is x, okay? It's just some
object out in the world and each hypothesis labels it. Plus or minus.
>> 'Kay.
>> Or can label it plus or minus. And H1 decides if for
that X, it's positive, and the other two hypotheses decide that it is,
in fact, negative and H1 has probability that is the maximum a posterior
probability h1 is .4, h2 is .3 and h3 is .3. So my question
is, very simple. Using all of the magic we've done, this is just to make sure
you've got it, Michael, I dunno, we've done
a lot of derivations, we've walked away from some
things [LAUGH] we gotta make sure we get back to basics here. What is the best
label for x? Is it plus, or is it minus? I see why this is tricky. Okay.
>> And go.